everybody gets to live the same way tell
me what rights we don't have what laws
that we don't have girl I'm going to
send you I want to I want to know say it
now if you're going to sit here and tell
us that we're missing rights that we are
not
allowed tell me we are approaching the
150th episode of middleground and we
need your help to continue making more
episodes join our middleground patreon
community and help us write the future
of Middle
Ground
[Applause]
the lgbtqia plus Community has moved too
far to the left girl how many letters
are there how many 100 it's difficult
because you know I think what was once
like a very loving and accepted
Community has pushed so far to the left
that you know we're seeing this massive
pendulum swing that is coming back the
other direction that is going to put our
entire Community unfortunately in danger
because has it it already has because it
has gone so far to the left rather than
being a good Common Sense middle ground
that now people who did not used to
carry a prejudice against us or have an
issue with our community are suddenly
finding themselves to have prejudice
against the lgbtq community we have
prejudice against ourselves that's
that's true even I'm developing
developing a pre like I can't stand
lesbians now like there are people here
and I'm not I won't call it individuals
but there are people here that I was
friends with that I literally went on
vacations with that have unfriended me
unfollowed me just for simply standing
up to or standing up for young lesbians
and gay men who are calling themselves
all these other genders or because I'm
not for children transitioning or just
because I voted for Trump you know and
it's a shame because we want to be we we
don't want to be rather we don't want to
be a hive mind right we are like the
whole point of being the one of the
points of us being lesbians is that
we're different we have different
outlooks on life we have different
talents I feel like with a lot of
marginalized groups the biggest
downfalls to them is simply when usually
outside groups create division a left
and a right the left doesn't accept the
right the right doesn't accept the left
and then that divides all of us instead
of being one powerful group it just
crumbles we divided I think it's
unfortunate that sexuality is tied to a
you know political Outlook to begin with
that is no longer like oh Republicans
don't want gay people to exist like
that's not a thing anymore and I think
so unfortunate how politicized our
entire Community has become I think it's
important to note that we're here
calling ourselves conservative lesbians
but we're really like some of us aren't
really conservatives we're just
non-leftists
and we haven't really moved like people
call me a grifter or whatever they want
to call me I haven't moved over the
years I've been stagnant like i' I've I
am set in my morals I'm in my mid-30s
like I know where I'm at and people
mainly the LGBT whatever Community moved
further and further left I stayed where
I was and somehow I was the one that was
ostracized well that's because what used
to be moderate is now considered
conservative and what used to be your
general liberal which I think a lot of
us at one point probably aligned
ourselves with is no longer that it is
so far past that which you know I had to
draw a hard line I'm not with this
anymore we all can have different
beliefs you can be this race and still
think this way or be this uh be gay and
think this way so it's just really sad
to see and I feel like a you know we our
community has been used so much to push
other things like we're being used as a
shield so everyone que for Palestine
really really go to Palestine as a queer
person see what
happens somebody's going to have to sit
next to
me conservativism itself means that you
like the things that are going now and
that traditionally it's going good for
you for us um I personally disagree with
that because of the things that I have
been through um the discrimination from
everyone doesn't matter whether they're
left or right or you know not part of
the community is not working for us it's
not working for me at least can I ask
you questions sorry I don't mean to
interrupt yeah for sure you know how
they the left people on the left have
redefined the word
woman what do you mean by that a lot of
people a lot of people that identify on
the far left LGBT or not have redefined
the word woman to mean basically
anything yeah I'm not binary I use the
pronouns yeah so there you go okay so
you so you have changed the meaning or
the whatever right
conservatism is just the opposite of
leftism at this point as far as I'm
concerned so I just want to make sure
that that is so what are you saying the
opposite of leftism could you cons the
new age conservatives are really old AG
Libertarians or like moderates or just
classic liberals for the most part so I
just just to make sure like we're on the
same page a little bit you know Ian
exactly so what I'm saying is that
because we are growing if you want to
include more people because technically
the lesbian flag has changed to an
orange stripe for non men such as myself
I still identify as a lesbian I'm still
here can I ask you how you identify as a
lesbian when you're not a woman because
I'm not I'm a non-man because that
that's a terrible definition in my
opinion but but that's that's fine
you're allowed to believe what you
believe because I believe in freedom of
speech but so I believe in including
everyone doesn't M it doesn't matter
what other people go by I think that
being left and having this conversation
go to Left means that we don't care
anymore everyone can be a part of the
community no matter who you are labels
don't matter as much as you know they
did back then because it was only the
LGB when we're moving towards the left
we're moving towards the you know the
future including more people sometimes
gatekeeping is a good thing though and
sometimes segregation is a good thing
why well why well how okay so you're
talking a lot you're saying that like
you guys are opening accepting more
everything like that so where's the
where's the line then because then we
have straight people so so then why have
a community if there's everybody's in
the community if you self-identify in
the community then we're all there for
each other doesn't if if you're straight
and you identify a straight you are not
part of the community I do not identify
as straight I identify as a non-binary
lesbian because the lesbian Community
has accepted me because I don't feel
comfortable in my gender identity
because growing up I didn't feel you
know accepted in the lesbian community
so now that we're moving left and we're
accepting more people into it I'm
finally accepted in the community people
you know actually do accept non-binary
lesbians if you don't identify as a
woman and a lesbian is a woman who loves
another woman then why would you not
identify as queer and yes we're going to
labels here but like genuine curiosity
I'm trying to understand because if a
lesbian is no longer a woman who
sexually attracted to another woman than
a lesbian can be anybody anybody which
is literally what's happening in in the
world right now the problem like
straight up dudes that are not trans
women straight up dudes going on lesbian
dating apps and and calling us
transphobic and I think there's a bit of
a gray area there if I sorry to
interrupt correct me if I'm wrong but I
I'm under the impression that with
nonbinary lesm there's a bit of a gray
area because uh you can often have a
very similar experience than um of a
woman who is a lesbian being non binary
because if you um because we're all
female you could say well if yeah if
you're a signed female at Birth and you
date women and you before you knew you
were nonbinary you were all um would
imagine you were often in lesbian spaces
and that's what you identified with so
why should you be excluded from that
Community just because now you know you
are nonbinary for example I think like
Cally speaking like now we Define
lesbian as being like non-men loving
non-men I think there's a very small
subset of people that Define it that
way c yeah absolutely but I think also
like language is always conformed around
people and communities like being trans
and being non-binary is not a new thing
this has existed in like premodern
Society it's not new um it's always
existed and language is always conformed
around people like we don't make things
up and then people start identifying as
them like we can form language to fit
identity and like it's always been that
way although I do think people make up
words and say that's also true no that's
also true there's 100 million genders
that people have literally just made up
it did not frog frog self what is it
affect you what other people identify I
don't I don't they self identify yeah
absolutely self identify as a potato I
feel like a very small group has become
the example there's a small group of
left and there's a small group of right
that are louder than everybody else and
everybody else is being forgotten
absolutely I think one thing that
separated us is that I think you often
and I'm not trying to just point out but
since you I am the friend of yours that
I cannot longer support you because you
don't support me right if
you I'm explaining right because I
believe that when you use your voice you
you were coming from a place of
privilege without realizing that the
things that you were sharing were
negatively attacking me and my lifestyle
you are able to have privilege because
you don't show up like I show up you're
not a woman of color you're you're not
masculine so it's easy for you to say oh
yeah this is okay but you're not
realizing that you're forgetting me and
my existence and what I might need we're
under attack
lgbtqia plus is under attack we have 650
plus anti-lgbtq bills attacking our
existence a lot of y'all talk about oh
how oh it's mostly attacking trans kids
which we all should be pissed if
anybody's attacking our kids we should
all be pissed but 350 plus attacking the
LGB which y'all want to just emphasize
and say everybody else doesn't count
it's it's this but we are all being
attacked and so for you to not see that
is privilege and I think that I I just
really need you to understand that would
you like to comment as a woman of color
yeah absolutely what what laws are
affecting lesbian women of color in
Florida right now um if there's a
lesbian couple because there's a lesbian
couple that are going through this right
now um right now if somebody calls the
cops on a lesbian couple see saying that
they're being inappropriate um they
could F jail time just for someone
calling them and having to go children I
know if that's true if that is then then
you text me cuz I'll go to the I've
never heard of that and there's not many
I I would love to hear all these laws
that are affecting me as I I am I am an
American and I have every right as
everybody else does I have nothing
stopping me from getting married owning
my own home starting my own business
nothing raising kids priv how is that
privilege how she's also a person of
color I'm a person of I know but you
show up differently than I do how but
but
you has no no effect on that so since
you and being black I I am also black so
what I'm black in Hispanic so what me to
what laws are different for you I would
like to okay well if you want to talk
afterward I got you I am on the board of
lamb illegal we're fighting these 650
plus anti-lgbtq BS I have a list for you
also there's so many documentaries the
thing is I think what you're you're you
want to just battle with me instead of
understanding that we just live
differently our experiences are
different so all I'm asking y'all to do
is understand that I'm not trying to
take away from you and whatever but
being able to be in that mindset without
understanding any somebody else's
experience is privileged and that's what
I'm trying to get y'all to understand if
I could butt in real quick I just I want
to go back to what you know earlier you
guys were saying you know kind of the
LGB blah blah blah that's also not
caring about the rest of the humans that
self-identify as those people we want to
respect those people even if we don't
agree with them we're still going to
respect them no matter what you know I
may not agree with you guys but I'm
still going to respect you and what you
self-identify as which hopefully you
will do the same to us which is what
you're saying that the left is becoming
right that makes no sense because we're
trying to advocate for the change the
right is advocating for keeping things
the way they are why we're running into
all of these anti-lgbtq legislation as
you put it is because things have gone
so far liberal that now we're facing
this backlash from the traditional Ultra
right Community which is why all these
bills are coming up which is endangering
our community as a whole and I think
that that is the basis of this we have
gone too far this way and now this side
is coming back to fight us I think there
has been a lot of progress in the last
few years well few decades and there is
definitely a backlash from the far right
because of that but I don't think the
solution to to that is just say oh let's
go back and be less Progressive I I
think we just need to carry on and there
will be backlash but eventually those
people will just get used to it but I
think it it is a shame to be so divided
because that can't be good for the the
community that's true but and we also
have to take accountability for our own
Community like we aren't above anybody
else we're not we're we need to take
accountability and call out when it
happens we can't sit here and just be
like oh poor me poor me Community
everyone hates us like what are we doing
why are why are these laws coming up so
most of the laws that are coming up and
the reason why acceptance of us has gone
down women and children are being
targeted when you that's it don't mess
with children women and children that's
not an attack against our community
that's people defending their group of
people you come for someone's kids
there's going to be lots of laws and I
hope that there would sorry you come
from women spaces I hope those women are
going there's going to be laws it's not
an attack on us it's attack on these
things happen happening and why our
acceptance is going down so much and I I
think like at at any point or you know
at any point in history something was
once considered like too Progressive too
radical and so like in this moment like
you believe that which is why I believe
that like I'm so Progressive because In
This Moment Like This may seem too
Progressive or too radical or too out
there and in 20 years from now like
maybe you know we'll be saying like oh
my gosh our kids they're so left and
they're so Progressive and they're so
radical and like we'll feel like they're
taking that charge and like they're
pushing and so like but like you know at
a time like wearing pants was so radical
and like you're all wearing pants except
for me like at a time like that was that
would have been insane right but like
like at this moment in time like you
know you're sitting there saying that
we're being too Progressive and like too
radical but like there was a point in
time when what you're all doing what
you're all wearing what you're all
saying would have been too Progressive
or too radical I feel like correct I
feel like comparing what somebody's
wearing to transitioning kids harming
children is a big leap I just we can get
that the point is although you guys are
saying be processive be open to
everybody let anything happen let
anything goes it's like when kids are
well that's kind of what she just said
things are constantly changing we're
going to look back and there has to
there has to be gatekeeping there has to
be there has to be there's kids being
harmed right now there are children
there are children committing suicide
and removing body parts at miners as
minors this is what my group does and
what I do eat breathe and sleep every
day and I see adult D transitioners
crying can't live their life and on the
verge of suicide because their parents
took them to a clinic where they got
breast removes at 12 years old their
breast removed at 12 years old and that
is starting people are fighting for
those rights to do that that's
disgusting our friend Chloe Cole was was
age that's less what is that one the
deter transitioners are less it does
matter I'm just maybe maybe the ones
that are I said I agree though the kid
situation I'm just saying we often
Target a very low percentage and make it
the example and that's what I feel like
conservatives and Republicans do is
y'all Target one example one situation
and act like it's the whole Community I
would date a trans
woman
bullsh well I
guess
well wow yeah you're surprised right see
a lot of people a lot of people don't
know I mean does she have a
vagina I don't like I don't like that's
a general preference not disgusting to
say General preference please don't call
it a general preference it's a sexual
orientation exactly so I don't prefer
vagina I don't like so when you're
saying sexual orientations you are
referring to who you are attracted to
when you are saying that you do not have
a preference for that genital portion
that is labeled as genital preference
that's your label that's not my label
sorry would you mind if I finish sorry
so trans women what the question is is
that's gender it doesn't matter whether
they've gone through their procedures or
not if we are dating a trans woman it
shouldn't matter whether they have a
vagina or a penis or anything so I
should I should like convince myself
that I have to be attracted to
somebody's genitals if I'm not I
personally would date a trans woman but
I don't think it's transphobic not to
want to and because that doesn't Define
whether that transwoman is a woman or
not just someone else's preference that
trans women are women regardless of
where they are at in their transition I
100% believe that but whether or not
someone is attracted to them because of
that doesn't affect who they are and uh
for me personally um I am more attracted
to the female energy like presentation
and being for me it's more about that
than what they have down there for me
personally but it's not like that for
everybody like and and I think that's
okay I don't think that's and I'm not
one of those people that's going to take
away the validity of how somebody
experiences themselves yeah but don't
take away my experience how I see myself
as a lesbian that's what this means to
me yeah it's different than someone
saying oh that's not a real woman I
don't want they I never said that yeah
that's different but someone just not
have not feeling attracted I don't think
that's a problem trans women are trans
women and and trans women can be many
different I don't think their I don't
think it's nice either to just say trans
women or trans women instead of but they
are well they are but they are also if a
transwoman is a woman then I can be a
transwoman as a woman no you're taking
woman an umbrella term I don't agree
with that though well trans is a
category of women so it could be a
blonde woman a trans woman pink woman
and when you specifically say trans
women or trans women you're kind of
saying that they're not the same as us
they're not they're not that that's
that's the whole purpose of them
transitioning right yeah I I also just
want to say that I think that when we're
talking about dating trans women or
dating trans people like like non-binary
people fall under the trans umbrella so
like like I would also include dating
non-binary people like I know we're
thinking about trans women specifically
but like non-binary people are trans and
like they also fall under that umbrella
and like you know there's I I feel like
any like non- man dating a non- man like
we've now defined as being a lesbian
would you date a woman with a penis I I
think that personally
I have a genital preference but
I currently like I would say that I have
a genital preference but I would never
rule anything out like I've dated
non-binary people um I wouldn't rule out
dating anyone who's trans I think I'm
also like a very Progressive and
open-minded person I wouldn't say that
if I Loved Someone That I would rule
them out for being trans I don't like
the fact that you used open-minded but
you're allowed to say that of course
it's your it's your yeah prerogative
just to say how you feel but to me
open-minded comes across as me being
closed-minded and I don't think you can
I'm just saying just saying like I'm not
close-minded because I have a sexual
orientation that's monosexual absolutely
thank you appreciate
that
hello I agree one is not better than the
other but we can all have our
preferences right I don't agree that
trans women are women trans women are
trans women trans women are men who have
suffered through gender dysphoria who
have transitioned into present as women
are going through surgeries taking
hormones that is perfectly fine there is
they're completely valid in who they are
but it's also okay for me to have a
preference meaning I'm not interested in
male anatomy now I have dated trans
people before trans men that's great I
love that but trans women it doesn't do
anything for me that doesn't make me
transphobic which is why I say no this
not that they're bad people there's
nothing wrong with them they're
completely valid individuals but I also
don't have to agree that number one
they're a woman because they're not and
and number two I don't have to say that
I'm attracted to them because I'm not
why do you say they're not women because
they're not why though if you could
because our our definitions of woman are
different you could say they're not
female but they're a woman because being
a woman is just a a gender is not
biological it's not the sex of the
person the gender identity separ so
here's where we have a disagreement
because I believe that sex and gender
are the same thing if you are born a man
you will always be a man now if you want
to transition to be a woman that's
awesome you can be exactly who you want
to be that doesn't change your
chromosomes that doesn't change the
hormones that your body naturally wants
to produce if you have to inject
yourself with hormones to become
something you are not that thing what
about inex people humans so going right
back to like the extremely small
percentage inex people are completely
valid but that's much more common than
people realize especially when you're a
woman like myself that produces more
testosterone all lesbians than most
women no mine's no you you don't you I
no is even more normal yes especially
athletes um just masculine women there's
women that suffer from PCOS I saying it
correctly um there's been women taken
out of uh that have medals taken away in
the Olympics and things like that
because their testosterone is higher
there's it's much more common that that
those things occur like especially with
interex humans Than People realize so
I'm just wondering how do you feel about
that because you touched on a very small
percentage earlier with the kids right
so can we that's fair yeah can we just I
just want to know how you feel that I I
have no issue with INX individuals again
we're going back to our orientation and
our preference if I was attracted to
someone who might be inex that's great
that's cool yeah I'm just I'm not or
maybe I've just never experienced
someone like that before and that's fine
too they're not invalid as humans
they're not invalid in their identity
but I don't have to change my attraction
in force an attraction just to help
fulfill someone else that it's not the
attraction I was wondering about it was
if they need to take you know something
to balance out their body to be able to
present as they're seeing how do you
feel do you are you saying that they're
not how they present because of that and
that's what I was asking that's a really
interesting question in in the case of
someone being born interex um which
given that is not something that I have
very deep knowledge on and I'm going to
go ahead and put that out there I don't
have you know very extended knowledge on
people who are inex but I don't see an
issue with that I really don't like if
you have to take hormones to present a
certain way have your voice go up go
down grow body hair not grow body hair
okay then you are forcing a change upon
yourself and that's simply the reality
of the situation or just balancing out
the body to be
healthy okay so we could also put this
say cismen who as they age start taking
testosterone replacement therapy trt
that doesn't make them not men that's
just balancing their hormones so yes I
can understand so then that kind of that
yeah so that's what I'm asking you to
think about when you think of the trans
Community as well you get what I'm
saying it's a really interesting thought
yeah okay thank you I I just that's all
I wanted you to do is just consider
something that's often missed sure in
the case of interex absolutely I can see
your point in the case of assigned
female at Birth assigned male at Birth
transitioning that's a completely
different ball
game I didn't get to talk earlier but I
love women you know uh um I I agree with
you earlier um of like I guess genal
preference but I'm not limiting myself
because if I meet a beautiful human I
have a connection with we'll figure it
out I don't know that's just how I feel
and um I just I don't know I just Al I
also just think that to assume that a
transwoman is
whether they have their parts or not and
if they use them in a traditional way is
a little bit gross to just that's not
true lead with that um no I I just I'm
just saying to automatically assume like
CU you went to are you going to Su a
date are you going to Second a date
often my trans women friends and the
ones that I've dated don't want to show
up that way in a sexual space so I think
it that's what I'm saying I think it's
it's gross to think about it like that I
think that there is Nuance to this
conversation I think I have the
fundamental understanding that if I'm
going to dat a trans man they are a
trans man which means they were born a
female which means they have female body
parts female hormones female chromosomes
that doesn't make them any less of a
person now I can be polite if I like
someone if I Vibe someone I have no
issue using your preferred pronouns I
have no issue addressing you how you
wish to be addressed but I also don't
have to
agree that men and women are the same
thing I also don't have to agree that a
man who transitions to a woman is
suddenly full force woman no he will
always be what he was now if I want to
use she her cool I can be respectful of
that but I'm not going to ignore basic
science in order to tiptoe around
people's feelings I I can I have a I
have I have an interesting story to tell
and a lot of people don't know this
about me but I dated you would say a
trans person is who they say they are no
matter what their transition stage is
correct absolutely so then I have dated
a trans man in the past and interest
while you identified absolutely yes so
then did you see him as a woman no okay
oh my sorry yes I'm sorry sorry yes not
after the fact she I I say she not
because I'm misgendering them because
I'm otherwise I'd be Mis sexualizing
myself Mis Miss seexual orientation
myself but they presented as a female to
me they were female they were fully
intact as a female they called
themselves lesbians they transitioned
later
on technically I did date a trans guy
does that mean I'm bisexual no I don't
think absolutely not absolutely not
identify as that when they were so I'm
bisexual then cuz I was attracted to a
man no they didn't identify as that when
they dated you so you're taking their
experience you just said that they trans
not from my knowledge but they well
you're born trans right if that's the
truth you you're born with gender
dysphoria so they always knew that they
had gender dysphoria and always knew
that they were internally a man whatever
mixing so many things up he was saying
that he was like a lesbian when you guys
were together he told me he was a
lesbian he pres he looked like her right
present as a woman okay so then you're
like taking someone's journey and making
it about you to be like I guess I'm
bisexual and I'm going do that's what no
but I agree with you then so we're we're
in agreement that I'm not bisexual you
can be firm in your lesbian identity
like so no matter who I sleep with I'm
no I'm just saying like despite having
dated someone who like transition like
after you guys broke up like you can
still be firm in your lesbian identity
because of the society and the media and
everything and you know people that are
pushing us down we don't realize that
we're trans until way later on in life
regardless of how he identified I was
attracted to him
because he was a woman yeah he was
female the point is the whole the whole
prompt would you date a transom not if
they look like a dude I don't understand
how a lesbian can be
conservative cute I think that was a
huge question that I really did have
going into this because like I said
earlier conservativism itself is keeping
things that the way that it is through
the EXP experiences that I have had that
my girlfriend has had that we all have
had um I don't like how it is right now
I would love to progress forward again
as a non-binary lesbian only through the
progression did I feel accepted did I
feel safe like did I you know that's how
I found my girlfriend stuff like that
moving forward and progressing forward
yeah the right has
famously being always against the LGBT
community and always
especially in the past has always fought
against um equal marriage and everything
so surprises me to see that there are
gay people who identify as conservative
I I think it's fine for people to have
their political opinions that are not
attached to their um sexuality of course
but at the same time for me it's hard to
support that's important a party that is
has always been historically against us
MH and like being conservative and like
being Republican I think are also two
separate things and like being
conservative like truly is about like
you know staying where you are or like
keeping things similar whereas like like
progressives like want to progress and
like move things forward and like being
people are Republican for all kinds of
reasons um but I think that it is
interesting that people can be in the
queer community and not be interested in
progress and change like especially as
like so many conservatives have been so
anti-lgbt for a very long time yeah yeah
I agree I I say the same I think there's
a difference between moderate and
conservative and you know just wanting
to live your life a certain way because
I know a lot of I would say more
moderate lesbians that don't want to
partake in the Prides and do things like
that they just want to live their life
with their wife and their kids and
that's very different because nowadays
conservative is combined now with
Republican in my eyes and so when you're
a republican lesbian you're yeah you're
against the our community moving forward
and progressing and you're also aligning
with the
oppressor and so that's why I have a
hard time understanding que's
being conservative or SL Republican
because you're aligning with the
oppressor and not going against change
in the positive direction for our
community for sure yeah I get the
impression that just because they don't
agree with certain parts of our
community or certain parts of the left
then they go all the way to the other
end of it when really that is not really
necessary because you can disagree with
people that are on your own side and
have different opinions um you don't
have to suddenly say oh yeah let's yeah
let's be a conservative now yeah like
part of I think like what is so like
amazing about being Progressive and like
being in a community of very Progressive
people is that like you can a difference
of opinion like not everyone's going to
feel like as left leaning as I am and
like not maybe people are more left
leaning than me I don't know maybe
somewhere um but I think that like
that's like what's so important that
like we're all like working towards like
making sure that people are equal and
like feeling supported and like can feel
affirmed in their identity and their
gender and their sexuality and I think
that conservatives are actively I think
work against that like that's where I'm
it's confusing that people who are queer
can be
conservative
what don't you have that you need to
progress further to get besides
acceptance cuz that may never come
equality well what then in what's not
equal um most I'm going to say queer in
general the community don't have
Protections in certain areas like where
you live you can't adopt um or you can
get fired on the basis of your sexuality
um the things are in place to protect
that but if it still Happ happening
often then that's why we need to
progress to make our life and our
lifestyle a norm so that we don't have
to face discrimination I I mean West
Hollywood in La is supposed to be a gay
Haven and I as a person that has hosted
parties there and been a promoter there
for 11 years and still and know the
owners still face discrimination almost
every single time I go there because
there's discrimination within our
community and so now I'm I'm as a
missioner I'm working on that because we
have to fight it even in this city that
everyone thinks that everyone's accepted
so can you imagine that in LA in West
Hollywood if that's going on how it can
be in other cities and towns and states
for people that look like us right well
I just don't see what laws politically
wise would would stop people from being
discriminated like people are that way
there's always going to be people who
are racist we're transphobic homophobic
what laws I guess what rights do we not
have we can adopt well there are many
countries where just being gay is well
that I by countries of course I'm I was
just referring to the United States but
yeah I totally agree on that other
countries absolutely they need to do
something about that but here I just
don't any lesbian couple can get married
have a kid adopt a kid have all those
I'm saying that because you said why do
you still need to move forward why why
do you feel they need to progress and I
think it's because developed countries
are leading the way in general for the
whole Comm now thinking about the when
you say people are always going to be
you know transphobic homophobic that's
why we want to progress because
hopefully one day and even if it is 300
years from now we don't want that to
happen of course oh you ask why is
acceptance going down acceptance is
going down it's statistically we are the
acceptance straight people and anyone is
is it's lowering why is that if we're so
Progressive why is it lowering because
we're going too far over we are now
attacking children's and women's spaces
I'm going to jump in right here um
because we're not just looking at social
issues whenever we're talking about
conservatism versus leftism or right
versus left yeah social issues are
absolutely a part of it but then we're
also looking at okay how are we taxed
how is the government spending our money
how much of our tax dollars are going
overseas how are our schools being run
how are our children being taken care of
do you have a nice library in your town
that you can visit all of that can be
traced back to your political leaning
and I think it's very important to
understand my sexuality has nothing to
to do with the way I think the
government should spend our taxes I can
understand like a lesbian being a
republican I can understand like a
lesbian like voting for a republican
like if that's your perspective and like
on whatever else and maybe that's you
know it's your your own prerogative who
you want to vote for it's not like we
have whatever all these choices um but I
think that we're talking about like
being Progressive versus being
conservative literally you want progress
or you want to conserve the past what
needs to be progressed Community there's
much no law is going to change that
whether you're Republican or or liberal
that's not going to going think about
social movements and social issues
across the board we think about the
acceptance of black people of gay people
like we think about how Progressive
movements have made us more comfortable
in our identities in Social spaces okay
then there but there are movements that
has nothing to do with politics can I
give you an example of the racial divide
in this country right laws were put into
place so African-Americans can vote and
be equal humans right and do you not
think that those protections put in
place allowed African Americans to be
more accepted as time went on absolutely
yes yes okay yes absolutely yes you say
no no I was I'm processing it think
think same thing I don't completely
agree though I I think saying that
there's so racist people today so that
didn't fix it but they can't for us yeah
it it it normalized and and brought
people together and not to see the
racial divide as inhu inhumane or I'm
you're not a human because you're
African-American that changed so what
we're asking is for equality so that our
us as humans are able to exist like
everyone else and and that we and and
and that there's a equal ground here
like just respect and that's what I'm
saying is it's very necessary to put
these protection in place so we can live
like everyone else but we do live like
everybody else there's no no I don't you
being able to say that is privileged
absolutely no no I'm not trying to for
you it is people are homophobic to me
too but it doesn't affect my life I
don't let that you say that no no no um
it's a privilege to not understand every
other people how do you know I don't cuz
you're asking me the questions well
yours is different than hers and hers
and hers exactly what my point was so
how can you tell me I'm privileged how
can feel safe how can you tell me I'm
privileged live I feel very safe you
show up differently than I do I show up
very differently than I do there's a
there's more Hispanic people in
probably are in California actually what
does that have to do that's what you're
talking about is that not what you're
talking about you're talking you walk
down the street in Florida and be cool
because I'm fam because I'm not like
100% like where where's I think that we
should take a trip to Florida and see
what it's really like what you hear and
Florida all the time but okay then is
there anything ever happened in Florida
I'm I'm those are very protected spaces
that I'm in and then when I do travel
around yes I've gotten death threats
I've had to shut down events that I've
done I've had um yeah people name me by
telling me to pick out a coffin tell me
not okay but those people are is what
we're kind of sorry to cut you off but
those people are inow now those people
are deciding the future of our country
and that Democrats no those people that
are hateful that are homophobic that are
transphobic unfortunately those people
are becoming in power we're not saying
that the these exact laws need be put
into place we're saying now people that
are following these people of authority
and you know are really listening into
it now these are the only thoughts that
they're thinking of there's no one in
place of a power really right now that
are pushing for the progression I'm not
a conservative because I'm a lesbian I'm
not a lesbian because I'm a conservative
I'm a conservative because I agree with
more than 51% of the conservative
beliefs amen I don't even agree with
100% of the conservative beliefs I might
even hold more liberal views on certain
individual topics than maybe even some
of you it's simply
race sexual orientation disabilities
none of
that puts people in a liberal
conservative or a middle box and I think
most of our disagreements today are
simply just because of language my
version of women her version of women
your version of women are all different
our versions of conservatives and your
versions of conservatives are completely
that's why I said it was important what
does this mean to us what does woman
mean what does conservatism mean what
does liberal mean cuz by definition by
the old school definition I am a liberal
yes I am Pro freedom of speech Pro equal
rights Pro capitalism pro- free markets
like that is a liberal yeah I think it's
just the language is completely evolving
and would I agree with conservatives 20
years ago probably not but language
fluidity everything is just constantly
moving and we just have to live within
our current reality we can't comp
compare you can't compare any of us to
conservatives 20 years ago just like we
can't compare you guys to liberals 20
years ago Pride should be taught in
classrooms join a middleground patreon
to watch this exclusive prompt
okay lesbians can use heem
pronouns
I think the reason why I steep forward
is because of the idea that pronouns
equal gender I think that's also why I
kind of hesitated as well because when
you're saying use he him pronouns at
first everyone assumes it's their gender
sexual orientation everything I think it
goes back to my belief that pronouns do
not equal your gender I like I know
non-binary lesbians who like go by any
pronouns and I think like there's you
know I think that there's maybe you meet
more non-binary lesbians who use they
them pronouns or use she they pronouns
but like I think that anyone who's
non-binary can use any pronouns and be
defined as a lesbian thinking of you and
thinking of my non-binary friends that
like you said use all pronouns and so
that's when I realized that I
agree I didn't step forward with the
rest of my team just because my first so
cute love you just because my first
thought was of when straight men call
themselves Les bians and I yeah and I
always thought that was so disrespectful
and cringy and that that was my first
thought that's why I was like oh no
straight away but then when you were
talking about nonbinary people was like
oh yeah that's true there are non-binary
people who also use he him pronouns uh
at the same time I still disagree a
little bit just
because if like if pronouns don't we
quote gender was the point point yeah so
I feel you I think to me it's a it's a a
bigger conversation than just somebody's
identity if we're in this community
trying to make the world understand us
more and trying to actually be
Progressive as you guys call it why are
we just trying to why are we also being
more confusing the only thing that that
winds up doing is making yourself feel
better yeah but I think what you're
saying with that is you feel you know
validity within yourself it doesn't
matter about what other people think you
know what the um outside Community
thinks I think we should just be
accepted of everyone no matter what so
you know even we have different beliefs
you know we're still going to respect
each other and understand that even
though our identity we feel validity
within it doesn't matter what other
people think and I love that I think
that's absolutely the best way to go I
think it's strength within yourself and
actual self- Lov and self uh you can
self- express the way you want to let
other people make you feel invalidated
is the worst thing you can do the reason
why I didn't step forward and I actually
struggle with this one because I am all
about freedom of speech you are free to
say whatever you want to use whatever
pronouns you want to present how you
want I don't care and so on one hand
yeah a lesbian can use whatever pronouns
they want because that's their right
that is protected in our constitution as
your freedom of speech but on the other
hand I am not obligated to validate that
and I'm not like in my opinion a lesbian
is a woman who loves another woman I
believe what I believe is a woman maybe
not everyone here agrees what a woman is
but I believe that so if I say a lesbian
is a female or a woman who loves another
female woman mhm then they're probably
going by she her pronouns right but then
they also have their freedom of speech
so it's very middle a little bit muddy
for me on this one you can go by
whatever you want it shouldn't matter to
what other to other people what you go
by if you are a lesbian then you are a
lesbian and me as a lesbian I'm going to
support you if you realize that you're
not a lesbian anymore it's fluid I'm
going to support you no matter what no
matter what pronouns you go by because I
have been in that case where I I wasn't
educated on what I could be I've gone
through everything under the sun I was a
gender fluid lesbian at one point I did
use he him pronouns at one point but
again through my self-identity I've
discovered who I am and I think by
knocking down people's journey and
Discovery is exactly what saying people
who use Heim pronouns cannot be a
lesbian because in their own
self-identity they see themselves as
getting to that journey and they are
going through things that we don't
understand I think that we can both
support respect and love individuals who
are going through their Journeys but
also be diligent to protect spaces
that's why we have tqi a plus you know
what I'm saying that is why our umbrella
has expanded to be what it is so that we
can both protect our spaces but also
accept love and encourage and support
individuals who are not quite sure what
they are quite yet and that's okay too
you can you can do both do you feel like
non-binary people are encroaching on
lesbian spaces like do you is that
something that you feel like is a real
like social issue or MH um depends on
what side of the non-binary spectrum
they're on I think that's what I was
going to say what do you mean by side
because non-binary itself means you do
not have a binary you want but you still
have a sex make it make sense let's
let's how about all of us together the
middle ground is let's make it make
sense before we push everyone else to
accept it well we always have work to do
yes right no matter what we all showed
up we all showed up here we all showed
up here showed up it's it's not just
like saying you're going to dismiss
someone just cuz you don't understand
it's it that's part of the work that we
have to do but you guys
we don't so you guys have to figure it
out we don't we want it to stay the same
right but right now not our
responsibility they're trying to undo
everything that we did to have equality
and so they're not taking away marriage
so they're that's on the list it's okay
it's on the list we talk like you said
we will talk about the bills after just
like interracial marriage is on the list
there's no bill out there that is going
to take away gay marriage right now but
but I'm saying you not being able to
understand that is privilege and that's
what I was that's what I was trying to
get understand I'm very reversed in laws
and
bills marriage equality to reverse
interracial marriage protection is on
their list sure okay that they would
like to undo okay I think we can all
agree right of course of course not but
but the thing is it's not that's not
happening that's not actually happening
okay so um certain things like
abolishing affirmative action is a part
of that process so just because you
weren't affected by it doesn't mean
you're about me I don't care what I
don't know why
it'sing how I affect I I'm not a
feelings person I don't go I don't like
laws change and all that based on things
I'm a f I'm a logical person too but you
don't understand what you're not
understanding is being able to have your
frame of mind is a privilege period you
can have the frame of mind too you're
not thinking about anybody else that
does not have the same privilege that
can walk like you walk that has access
like you have access not everybody know
how do you know that because of the way
you
you don't know anything about me it I
don't have to it's the way you're
speaking in your way that you're able to
not put a label on experiences I include
everybody's experience I just said that
multiple times you're thinking about
yourself and your experience that's
exactly I have to I speak for a huge
part of our community so do I okay so do
I I don't think so when you're trying to
say that we have enough protections and
and enough equality where we at I no
you're not talking about we have I'm
asking what don't we have do you think
that we do not deserve all the same
rights as everyone else and that we
can't we should not keep progressing to
get that we have all the same rights as
everyone else and that's privilege okay
cool thank you but people not in the
community also been trying to make
people and think that is privilege
because not everybody get live the same
way tell me what rights we don't have
what laws that we don't have girl I'm
going to send you I want no say it now
say it now if you're going to sit here
and tell us that we're missing rights
that we are not allowed
to some Families First of all marriages
gay marriages in certain states are not
they do not have the same benefits I
already shared that with you earlier
about gay families being able to adopt I
already shared that with earlier okay
gay families not being able to be a part
of churches I said that there's so many
things but that also happens to straight
people too some certain straight people
get married and they don't they're not
allowed to have certain benefits that
that happens to that's not a gay
specific thing what rights do you are
you able to get married in this country
are you able to adopt a child are you
able to do what you want to do and make
content on the internet I will have and
other people are not but that's not a
community issue I'm not going to have
the same Journey as if I wanted to adopt
me myself I'm not going to have the same
Journey as a straight couple trying to
adop course not but nobody El that same
straight person may not have the same
Journey as another straight person the
same biases lined up against there's no
law that you can't do it though there's
no law that you can do it what's the
bias Protections in place and they
cannot people don't like it okay that's
one thing there's no law that's going to
change it you don't be
listening gay men are more socially
accepted than
lesbians bye
guys so I definitely agree with this um
first off there's hardly any spaces for
lesbian only welcome no welcome Happy I
thought of something I thought of
something um also you know when you see
two gay men out in the street holding
hands kissing there's not a woman that's
going to be like o I'm going to get in
between that and I'm going to you know
but when it's the lesbian that's what
men do to us so no that is less socially
acceptable if anything a woman's like oh
a gay man let's be best friends let me
meet your partner where guys are like I
want to be your friend for ulterior
motives back to the f
exact yeah so that's what we face so
that's a social in society um also with
just spaces you hard there was like at
least where I'm from there's like 10
bars on a street they're all gay gay per
gay bars um which lesbians can go to but
there's one small little bar that's like
lesbian only it's like I don't know it's
just yeah yeah abolutely how do you guys
feel I agree with it what you just said
yeah I think I think it's interesting
and then the thought that I had when I
was back there is that Les Ians are more
accepted in my experience by people that
are not on the left and gay men are more
accepted by people that are on the left
and I think it has to do with the whole
reversal
of I'm trying to think of the word the
whole the whole reversal of
um I can't think of the word give me a
minute go to somebody it'll come to me
give me a minute because I was trying to
think of how to say it over there too
yeah absolutely um I completely agree
with you I think you know going away
away from politics and you know going
away from liberal and conservative ideas
lesbians are fetishized they are um
their rights are not being as spoken
about as gay men because yes gay men
have had it harder in the past I will
say that gay men have gone through a lot
worse than the lesbian Community has but
because of that reason we've progressed
so much in the gay you know for gay men
the the progression for lesbians haven't
quite gotten there and I think that's
what we're trying to do is get to that
point where we can have the same
progressions that gay men did have I
think that's a fantastic point and I was
going to say feminism feminism like oh
yeah and I think it says a lot that you
call yourself a non-man and I I don't
think I've ever met a man that called
himself a non-w woman and I think that's
a really important thing to note that's
going on on one side of the aisle with
lesbians but not with gay men and I
think that to me it just shows that
there's a little a a little a lot of
misogyny still on on coming from the
left in my opinion true yeah that that's
actually the I me as a human as an
individual I feel like everyone has
especially in our community and the
lgbtqi plus Community has had
experiences and like negative
experiences and discriminations all of
that but with me as like what I part of
what I do for a living being in the
political space um I see that
specifically sis white gay male have it
a lot easier than everyone else um as
far as um ownership
um
career finances Access America yeah in
general and so and that's what I see and
that's what I was talking about earlier
with the things that I'm fighting for
I'm fighting for space because we don't
have that you said you mentioned a small
bar we don't even have that that's where
I'm coming from as well where I say it's
important for lesbians to have their own
spaces and to know what a woman is and
to know what a lesbian is because we
have so few of those spaces already and
to open it up to everybody that
everybody's queer now where's my
community right and um as a person that
tries to create space for people I often
have to fight battles of them not want
them wanting to give us nights that are
like the off nights not the popular
nights because they think us as lesbians
don't make enough money to you know to
for that space for that night and are
often times I'm finding that my bar
percentage or whatever has to be much
higher in order to have that space so
then as a person that tries to create
space I'm finding it very difficult for
us to have space um especially in the
community of where it's primarily white
sis male sure yeah sure
yeah I think for me that this is kind of
a very gray area question I think in in
media like movies and TV shows men
definitely have it better there's a lot
more gay male movies whereas I just had
this conversation with my girlfriend all
the Les the very few lesbian movies that
there are it they usually end up being
very sad and either they break up or one
die or they go back they're all
depressing and there maybe y'all got to
make the movies yeah there's no ending
I'll I'll buy it but like lesbians in
public spaces I feel have it better
because we we're kind of very masculine
forward gay men are not very for the
most part seen is not very masculine so
they tend to get bullied more if they're
even if they're not which is also a
misogyny thing yeah exactly even if
they're not gay if you're just a more
effeminate man you're it's going to be a
harder time whereas even I've always
dressed very masculine this is probably
my most feminine outfit I have and it's
fine I'm not really bullied for it I'm
not I mean in school sure but not not in
real life so I think gay men have it
better in TV and media and lesbians have
it better from my point of view in real
life yeah and I hate to you know uh say
this again but again that is a privilege
I personally being a masculine presented
I ha I I'm confident in myself but I
hate it I hate having to go out and be
spit on and be you know yelled at from a
window because I am masculine presenting
um the other day on my birthday I was
getting my free pancakes at IHOP and
this man came up to me called me you
know called me these words that I don't
like me being masculine presenting has
even made it worse for me but I do
understand what you were saying about
that I just me personally I don't have
that sort of privilege which I
definitely it's definitely just my my
lived experience I've never been bullied
for it but that doesn't make yours any
less valid I mean and I'm definitely
really sorry that that happened that
should not happen period absolutely I'm
sure we all agree on that yeah why did
you disagree
um I think that generally speaking it is
more difficult for men to be accepted
socially in the real world for being gay
especially if you have a man who is very
feminine um very like you know maybe
just not your typical what people
perceive to be masculine maybe he
doesn't align with that and I think that
he gets a lot tougher from other men
than maybe we do from women you know I
always been very masculine presenting I
have nobody cares if a girl wears guys
clothing but everyone has an issue
whenever a guy puts on girls clothing
and I think that if we just simplify it
to that level we can see where societal
society's acceptance is at you know it's
it's not an issue for me to cut my hair
short I used to wear a mohawk wear
dude's clothing all the time nobody
cares but then you put a guy in the same
situation where he's wearing maybe some
leggings and a crop top or you know then
all of a sudden people are looking at
him a certain kind of way that they
don't necessarily look at me and maybe
that's just my lived experience where
I'm at maybe that's my certain community
but from my perception I think the guys
actually have a lot harder than we do
yeah I agree and I think it's because of
misogyny because there's this
expectation of men to be so Butch so
masculine that when they don't live up
to this expectation they're judged
really harshly yeah yeah I think that
like I mean I think I was agreeing with
what you guys were saying earlier
especially from like a social
perspective like I think lesbians like
we're so few and far between we have
like barely any social spaces barely any
bars like especially from like a social
like me other lesbians in the real world
is like we definitely like that is it's
shrinking like every single day um but I
do think that like um I the only reason
I didn't step forward is I think that uh
it all really goes back to like you
saying misogyny like patriarchy like gay
men I think are thought of as being like
aligned more with women and I think we
are somewhat more aligned with men
because we're attracted to women or
non-men um and I think it all goes back
to like patriarchy and misogyny and I
think that like that hurts all of us it
hurts gay men it hurts lesbians um I
think that like not to race I think like
like you guys were both saying like
being masculine and being butch and like
identifying and lesbians used to have to
dress that way to identify each other
and like see each other in the real
world so like I don't want to erase like
how hard it is to be like visibly queer
um but I think that patriarchy harms us
all it harms gay men it harms lesbians
it harms like all Queer people because
we have to align ourselves like within
patriarchy to like be safe and I think
that you know maybe we're
non-threatening to men in some ways
because we all like women or you know
but gay men are not non-threatening cuz
I don't they're not liking women or
whatever but it's it's all harmful
because it's
[Music]
patriarchy